l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 199 de Monsieur
jean-Patrick Courtois à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur vous avez la
parole chers collègues merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je
voulais appeler l'attention du ministre
de l'Intérieur que vous représentez ce
matin sur les conséquences de
l'application de l'article 46 du code
électoral dans les communes associées
comme vous le savez cet article prévoit
que dans les communes de 3500 habitants
et plus les électeurs doivent présenter
un titre d'identité pour pouvoir voter
cette mesure est destinée dans les
communes où la population est importante
et plus mobile à permettre aux membres
des bureaux de vote de s'assurer
d'identité des électeurs de facto cette
disposition s'applique également aux
communes qui sont associé à une commune
comptant une population supérieure à
3500 habitants dans la mesure où le
critère déterminant l'obligation de
présenter un titre d'identité et celui
de la population municipale de l'entité
communale totale donc inévitablement ces
petites communes souvent rurales dont la
population est souvent inférieure à 1000
habitants se retrouve soumise à ces
nouvelles règles puisqu'ell dépasse le
seil des 3500 habitants de par leur
nouveau statut de commune associé par
conséquent l'application de l'article
R60 du code électoral dans ces petites
communes peut générer des difficultés et
des incompréhensions pour illustrer mon
propos prenant l'exemple de trois
communes avec une population
respectivement de 953 personnes 500
personnes et 300 personnes qui sont
associés à une commune de plus de 30000
habitants ces trois communes présentent
toutes les caractéristiques des communes
rurales avec une population parfois
établie depuis plusieurs décennies et où
tout le monde ou presque se connaît bien
souvent les électeurs de ces communes
associées ne comprennent donc pas que
les membres de leur bureau de vote
exigent d'eux la production d'un titre
d'identité alors que le président et les
membres du bureau de vote issus de cette
même commune connaissent personnellement
la plupart d'entre eux cette
incompréhension est d'autant plus grande
que les communes limitrophes qui compte
une population plus importante mais sans
pour autant dépasser le seuil de 3500
habitants ne se voit pas appliquer un
tel contrôle cela aboutit
malheureusement régulièrement à des
tensions dans l'enceinte même des
bureaux vote tension qui s'avère peu
compatible avec l'ordre et le calme dans
lequel les opérations de vote doivent se
dérouler il me paraîtrait donc opportun
de s'interroger sur le nonsens de cette
règle d'autant plus que ces communes à
faible population disposent de leur
propres bureaux de vote de leur propre
liste électorale et fonctionne donc de
manière autonome dans ces conditions ne
serait-il pas envisageable de
reconnaître chaque commune associée
comme une entité unique à laquelle
s'appliquerait la règle é dictée pour
les communes de moins de 3500 habitants
cette disposition permettrait de
préserver le bon déroule des opérations
dans les bureaux de vote elle traduirait
par ailleurs une volonté d'intégrer et
de reconnaître à part entière ses
communes associées dans le processus de
l'intercommunalité je serai donc
monsieur le ministre avoir votre avis
sur cette proposition merci chers
collègues la parole est à Benoît amont
ministre chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et de la consommation vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur courtois vous avez interrogé le
ministre de l'Intérieur sur les
modalités de vote dans les sections de
commune manuel Vals s'excuse de ne
pouvoir être présent parmi nous et m'a
chargé de vous apporter la réponse du
ministère de l'intérieur comme vous le
rappelez l'article R 60 du code
électoral prévoit que les électeurs des
communes de 3500 habitants et plus
doivent présenter au président du bureau
de vote un titre d'identité en même
temps que leur carte électorale au
moment du vote cette disposition vise à
garantir la sincérité du vote dans les
communes de moins de 3500 habitants il
est considéré comme vous l'avez indiqué
que le président du bureau de vote qui
est le maire ou le conseiller municipal
dans l'ordre du tableau est en mesure de
connaître l'identité de chacun des
électeurs et la vérification de
l'identité résulte alors de la seule
présentation de la carte électorale dans
les communes issues de la fusion
d'anciennes communes celles-ci peuvent
au moment de la fusion constituer des
communes associées et en application de
l'article
l255-1 du code électoral ces dernièrre
forme de plein droit des sections
électorales dans certains cas ce qui est
le cas que vous évoquez des communes
fusionné de 3500 habitants ou plus
regroupe une ou plusieurs sections
électorales qui comprennent moins de
3500 habitants en l'état actuel du droit
aucune disposition juridique ne prévoit
de règles spécifiques sur les modalités
de contrôle d'identité dans ces sections
et de ce fait la présentation d'un titre
d'identité est par conséquent
obligatoire s'agissant d'une commune de
3500 habitants et plus et ce même dans
les sections électorales qui comprennent
moins de 3500 habitants vous souhaitez
donc que c setion soit soumise à un
régime dérogatoire qui n'exige pas la
présentation de ce titre d'identité par
analogie avec les dispositions prévues
pour les communes de moins de 3500
habitants le gouvernement considère que
cette proposition est cependant
susceptible de créer des
incompréhensions parmi des électeurs
d'une même commune dont certains
seraient tenus de présenter un titre
d'identité quand ils appartiennent à une
section électorale de plus de 3500
habitants et ceux qui ne seraient pas
conduits à présenter un titre d'identité
quand ils appartiennent a une section de
moins de 3500 habitants par ailleurs
elle peut présenter un risque de
contrôle moindre de l'identité des
électeurs et donc de mise en cause de la
validité des votes dans certaines
sections en effet s'il est fréquent que
la présidence des bureaux de vote des
sections électorales soit assuré par le
conseiller municipal issu de la section
aucune disposition n'impose une telle
obligation aussi dans le cas où pour
quelque raison que ce soit le conseiller
municipal qui est désigné par le maire
comme président du bureau de vote ne
serait pas issu de la section il ne
pourrait pas connaître chaque électeur
et ne serait pas en mesure d'exiger un
titre d'identité de ceux d'entre eux
qu'il ne connaîtrait pas je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le sénateur vous souhaitez
répondre à Monsieur ministre juste un
mot pour dire au ministre que si
effectivement je partage l'analyse je
partage pas ses conclusions parce que
sur le plan pratique c'est un frein
manifeste à l'idée d'intercommunalité
chez les habitants et j'ai j'étais
moi-même dans un des bureaux de vote
d'une des communes associé de la la
ville de Macon qui fait 500 habitants et
je peux vous dire que l'ensemble des
électeurs de cette petite section ne
comprennent pas qu'alors qu'ils se
connaissent tous qu' sont tous là ils
comprennent pas qu'à eux on leur oblige
d'avoir une carte d'entité alors que la
commune d'à côté on leur demande rien et
le risque que vous évoquez de dire
pourquoi dans la grande ville on demande
une carte d'entité pasant la pendant la
petite section ça opposerait les
électeurs ou autrre le risque est voisin
de zéro c'est c'est j'allais dire
faciliter l'intercommunauté que de leur
dire vous garderez quand même des
prérogatives d'autant que dans les
communes euh si on le souhaite et ce qui
était le cas de Macon et de mon
prédécesseur qui l'avait fait nous avons
laissé une commission consultative qui
s'apparente à un conseil municipal et
c'est eux qui tiennent le bureau de vote
donc je crois qu'à un moment où on parle
d'intercommunité on parle d'association
il semblerait que cette disposition
pourrait être revenue mais je me
permettrai de déposer un amendement dans
le cadre de la de de la de réforme des
décentralisations qui va pas manquer
d'arriver sur le bureau du Sénat merci
Madame la présidenteci